Film Courage: With YOUNG ADULT fiction,
one of the tests should be, is it enjoyable
to adults.
And that if it’s not [enjoyable], maybe
a Young Adult readership would be bored because
it’s not sophisticated enough?
Jennifer Brody:  That is a really great
question.
I would say that kids tend to read up which
means that whatever the age range that we
specify for these books, I find that they
tend to read up.
I was reading Stephen King and Anne Rice when
I was in middle school and high school.
But I probably started out reading things
like Judy Blume and things that skewed a little
bit younger.
I think it does need to have a certain level
of sophistication to hold a teen audience
now.
If it skews too old…I mean my books are
considered more cross-over for some of the
reasons I was talking about.
I have some adult points-of-view.
That it is a third-person, multiple points-of-view
story.
So when I was originally trying to sell it,
we got a lot of feedback like this is cross-over,
we don’t know how to market it.
Isn’t that a good problem?
Wouldn’t it be better if it appeals to both
teens and adults?
So the publishing industry has been a little
slow to catch up this idea that a lot of adults
are actually reading young adults and that
teen readers do tend to read up.
So I think they’re a little behind in understanding
that.
But I think it is to the benefit if the book
is a little more sophisticated and a little
more appealing to teens and adults.
But yes, I think you need to keep their attention.
Another thing that I think is important in
which we really tried to do with my series
is to put the books out in a relatively quick
timeframe.
Because also readers will grow out of reading
something.
So if you have multiple years between books
coming out, I think you’re doing yourself
a disservice because by the time the second
book comes out [your YA readership] they’re
going to be in college and then the third
book, who knows?
So we’re trying to do six months apart on
my trilogy because I think that makes a lot
of sense.
Film Courage: Is there a focus group that
you’re running the semi-edited version through?
Jennifer Brody:  I don’t really have a
focus group.
I think that when you first start writing,
a lot of authors have critique partners which
are really important to the process which
would be trusted readers which you trust to
give feedback on your manuscript.
I have another author which I trade books
with and he writes stuff totally different
from me.
Typically these days it’s non-fiction, WWII
Nazi books, so they are totally different.
But he’s really smart and we trade reads.
Now that I have a publishing deal and that
I have a big publishing team, I don’t do
that as much and I don’t really have the
time.
So my team of people who are reading and giving
feedback are my agent and my editors at my
publishing house so and at this point I am
really tailoring the books to them because
that is who is going to be distributing my
book.
And at this point I am really trying to keep
a consistency in the story and I kind of know
where I am and how I am writing it, so I’m
not at a place where I need feedback so much
on how I am writing, if that makes sense?
In the beginning a lot of it is trying to
improve the craft.
I’m at a point now where I am really trying
to tell the best stories that I can because
I already have a style that I’ve developed
in how I write.
So I am looking forward to writing something
different and new and I’m sure I’ll be
using critique partners on that once I start
writing my next book.
Question for the Viewers:  Do you read YA
Fiction?